dans cette réserve nous avons tous les
autres objets qui n'ont pas pu être
exposés à l'état puisqu'il y avait une
cloison qui sépare et le bureau de
monsieur 6ea de celui de sa secrétaire
le simple fait d'abattre la toise ans à
un réduit l'espace d'exposition et donc
nous avons préféré garder ces objets
dans une réserve
guinot frais à l'abri des regards a
certes mais nous espérons un jour pour
voir les exposer une autre manière au
public alors nous retrouvons certaines
photos par exemple en ce moment et à
l'exposition d'henri viii ghana nous
avons une photo de rihanna qui l'a
offerte à monsieur 6 heures nous avons
des cadeaux du bénin du chili nous avons
aussi quelques distinctions qui sont
affichés et même si on veut retrouver
également l'état devient a d'autres qui
sont encore dans la réserve
en quelques mots aimé césaire c'est
d'abord une humaniste
c'est un homme qui aimait vraiment les
gens il avait un amour inconditionnel à
vis à vis des gens qu'il rencontrait
qu'il recevait
quelle que soit leur catégorie sociale
leur parcours politique
c'était d'abord l'être humain qui
comptait et 7,6 tous et ce toujours ce
qui m'a marqué dans sa façon d'être sa
façon de faire je n'ai connu bien ta
c'était déjà dans les années 2000
après son sont arrivés ici en tant que
maire honoraire mais ce qui m'a toujours
ému c'est ça sa relation avec les gens
et surtout avec les enfants c'était
quelque chose d'extraordinaire c'était
comme une cure de jouvence et surtout
chose c'est ce qu'il m'a toujours
intéressé dans dans sa façon d'être
après c'est vrai que le politicien quand
on apprend à mieux le connaître on
comprend le para qu on comprend pourquoi
il a dit certaines choses fait d'autres
la création de son parti le choix de ne
pas demander la dépendance trop la
martinique
et puis sakarya thérère paiement qui est
très imagé beaucoup de personnes pensent
que dire aimé césaire c'est très
compliqué je pense qu'il faut prendre
son temps se poser lire mais aussi après
on utilise vos dictionnaires mais il y a
c'était un amoureux de la nature il ya
beaucoup de poèmes qui décrivent la
nature qui décrivent la femme c'est
extraordinaire de découvrir les textes
d'aimé césaire